so i have the number 235
and we can think of that as two hundreds
we have a two in the hundreds place so
two hundreds three tens we have a three
in the tens place so three tens and five
ones we have a five in the ones place
and over here i've actually drawn it out
with that many boxes this is
235 boxes so you have two groups of a
hundred boxes so this is two hundreds
then we have three tens one two three
and then we have five ones now let's try
some interesting things here so what
happens if i were to
add
add 10 here
well adding 10
we're just adding 110 we're just adding
1 10.
so if we add 110 what's going to happen
well over here i need to add one more
10. i got to add this 10. so what's it
going to look like well that the next 10
is going to look like this let me see if
i can draw it pretty fast
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine and ten one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten so i
just added a ten so what does that leave
us with
well if i had three
if i had three tens and i have one more
ten now now i'm going to have four tens
now i'm going to have four tens let me
do that in that yellow color
so now i'm going to have
four
tens i'm still going to have five ones
five ones i'm still gonna have five ones
i'm not adding any ones there
so i'm still going to have five
ones
and i'm still going to have two hundreds
i'm not adding any hundreds there
so i'm still going to have two hundreds
two hundreds so now it's going to be two
hundreds plus four tenths plus five ones
two hundreds plus four tens plus five
ones well what's that going to be
well
two hundreds
plus
four tens
plus five ones two hundred and forty
five
let's do one more instead of adding a 10
let's add 100.
so let's do that let me see if i can
clear all this stuff out
so
so instead of adding 10 let's add 100
here
so i'm going to add so plus
let's add
one
and i'll actually do it in yellow and
blue so i'm adding 100 0 tens and zero
ones so essentially just adding one
hundred
so this is
going to be equal to so plus one hundred
so plus
one
hundred so what's that going to get me
well let me draw it out here let me copy
and paste i have 200s before but i'm
going to add
100.
so let me just
copy that and let me paste it
so now
how many hundreds do i have
how many hundreds do i have now
well now i have one two three hundreds
i have three hundreds so over here i had
two hundreds i'm adding one more hundred
right over here so now i have three
hundreds
over here i could say that now i have
three
hundreds
now are the number of tens have they
changed no i had three tens before and
i'm not adding tens this time so i'm
still going to have three tens
and i had five ones before and i'm not
adding any more ones so i still have
five ones so i have
335 which is the same thing as three
hundreds
plus three tens
plus
five ones